[Music]
let's go to carol in tucson what's up
carol
hi john how are you i'm good how are you
um well i'm a little paralyzed with fear
to take action on something very very
important all right let me help you
yeah so our 33 year old son has been
hospitalized twice voluntary voluntarily
as being suicidal
one that the first one was in november
of 18 and the second december of 2019
and he's been living with us
and he pretty much just lives in his
bedroom
we rarely see him
and he hasn't gone to any counseling
other than at the very beginning of this
ordeal which we became aware of about
three and a half years ago
so my question for you is how do we
encourage him to go get counseling
um
and and my paralyzation comes from the
fact that i'm just so afraid i'm going
to say the wrong saying the wrong thing
and cause him to feel like he's a burden
to us and then cause him to take his own
life hmm
i'm sorry this is happening
you love that boy huh
well very much yeah
um has this
has he struggled his whole life
um
he he at one time said to me he feels
like he's been depressed his whole life
but um you know he went on to do great
things he
um double majored in college went on to
the army um
and became a captain and then when he
came out
went to seek a job that didn't come
easily as easily would have thought i
guess and
so my whole thought in this whole time
is that it was just the readjustment
coming out of the military that was very
challenging
so one of the
one of the challenges that parents
experience
when they have an adult child wrestling
with mental health issues
is a couple of things one
they try to roll back and see what they
could have done different to get to this
point and they carry a lot of blame and
a lot of shame and a lot of shoulders or
i might haves or what ifs i had done
this is is that any so any part of that
your story
um
well it's my story every day
now
not really retracing my steps but
i research the hell out of things um to
try to figure out what it is that he has
and what i should be doing
and what i should be saying and what i
shouldn't be saying
but he's treated by the va and he has
not allowed us to be privy to that
treatment okay
so
do you have two paths forward here
okay
one path is to make peace
he's just going to use your house as a
hotel he's not going to be a member of
your family he's just going to
live in his bedroom
and extrapola i mean fast forward 10
years
he's going to be 44 and then go 10 years
after that he's me 54.
and um
just going to kind of be what he does
and he's going to be in his room on the
internet playing video games or whatever
and he's going to come out for dinner
that you're going to provide him he's
going to go back in there and you're
going to make peace with it you're going
to stop worrying about it
and
you're going to move on with your life
the other side of it is
you're going to say
this stops now
and here's what this stops means
if you're going to continue to live here
then
a part of you living here is giving us
access to your doctor so we can be a
part of your healing
because i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna
sit ringside and watch my son die and
wither away to nothing
i'm not gonna watch my son
maybe not commit acute suicide pulling a
trigger or taking some pills or jumping
off something but i'm also not going to
watch him
commit what they call long tail suicide
just slowly fade away i'm not going to
sit down and watch that if that's want
to be the life that you want to choose
for yourself not that he's choosing
mental health and not issues and not
that he's choosing to hurt he's not
but if he doesn't want to choose to heal
then i'm not going to sit ringside and
watch that happen in my home
and honestly you as his mom and is dad
still in the picture
yes
you all two have to make that decision
on which path you want to take and
there's really only two paths the third
path you could take is to let them live
there and just fret and nag and
try new things and get a dog and then
get a
pool and do all these things and
mortgage your
you know take out a second mortgage on
your house and put you and your
husband's
retirement in jeopardy oh you can you
could try a bunch of stuff but what
you're gonna do is you're gonna you are
gonna drive yourself nuts you're gonna
give yourself
anxiety and heart attacks and strokes
and all that prematurely right so
the the path forward is just making
peace
this is just gonna be the way this is or
we are going to draw some boundaries
aimed at healing with the understanding
that when we draw boundaries
other people can choose to draw their
own
and his boundary might be well then i'm
out of here
and you have to decide
is that better
than him being in his room slowly dying
is it better than him to go leave
somewhere
because right now he's not getting any
better
is that you hear what i'm saying
i do hear what you're saying so in in
that conversation as we take option two
or if we encourage option two or we draw
the boundary to go with option two
in that conversation is it that we're
making it more about
that we
like you said you don't want to see him
sit around and
die of slow no see that's the thing i
start getting hung up on the words and
that's paralyzed yeah so let me let me
show you this you are not going to say a
thing and he's going to go no i haven't
thought of that now i'm going to go kill
myself
if you have a hard conversation with him
and he walks out of that room
and dies by suicide
that is not because you said the wrong
thing
okay okay that's because
he was struggling he wasn't well and he
made a decision
okay okay
the longer you don't have a conversation
the the messier this whole thing gets
and so when somebody
um
let me just let me put it this way i'm
not going to tell you what to do in your
world i'm going to tell you what would
happen if that was a friend of mine okay
if somebody calls and says um hey i
heard that so and so one of our buddies
is struggling
and this happened somewhat recently
i hung up the phone i picked them up and
i called and said hey
i heard you're not doing okay and they
explained some stuff and then i cut them
off and said hold on before you keep
talking are you going to kill yourself
and you want to talk about like
no man my kids and i was like no no
that's not what i'm asking i need you to
tell me yes or no are you going to hurt
yourself
no
now i didn't
put a thought into this person's head
that wasn't suddenly there
it was like no way i didn't think of
that yeah now that's not how that works
okay
um okay people do respond to boundaries
particularly if they have deep mental
illness
um
they he could respond in an extreme way
okay there is that possibility
um
that would not prohibit me and my house
from taking taking having that
conversation
let me think of it this way okay
not um
let's say somebody
uh has colon cancer
and they're on some sort of
experimental
um chemotherapy
and
they're not taking their chemotherapy
drugs and we've heard about stories
where where out of nowhere somebody goes
to the doctor for their annual checkup
and it's just gone the tumor's gone it
just went away
and also they say hey uh
colon cancer is a bad one let's do lung
cancer and then um
or they just go home and just keep
smoking
at some point i'm gonna say
you cannot sit in my house and continue
to smoke
and they may say
um if you send me out of here i'm gonna
die
you are sending me to my death nope i'm
not
i'm offering you life
if you stay here we're gonna walk
alongside you i'm gonna give you a place
to live we're gonna give you food we're
gonna give you water we're gonna give
you shelter and we're gonna to have a
close connection with your doctor
and that's your rent for being here
you can choose to keep smoking
i'm not going to watch you do it
i can't
[Music]
and i'm willing to offer you something
else does that make sense
yeah it makes a lot of sense
the challenge here is um
it might be something like this uh i if
i were you i'd also call the va
and i would let them know they can't
even acknowledge that he's a client
there um or wherever he gets is he
taking meds of any kind
yeah okay
you can look on the pharmacy i mean you
can look at the pharmacy whatever doctor
wrote that prescription you can see that
yes
i would send that doctor a note
of some sort or call
and say i know you can't confirm that my
son's even a client because he's 34.
we're about to have a hard boundaries
conversation in our home
and he has a history of suicidality
if this is a bad choice please let me
know
and put that burden on them
okay okay
but that's what i would do okay
and then there's a ethical obligation if
they know that there have a client in
harm's danger in harm's way
that this
you know maybe
your son told them if they ever do this
i am immediately going to do this in
this way at this time then they would
have an obligation to come out and say
something
okay
okay you are between a rock and a hard
place
there's no question about it
the question you have moving forward is
am i gonna make peace with the way
things are
or am i going to draw a boundary and
tell my son i want to be a part of your
healing
and i'm not going to sit here and watch
you slowly fade away in my home
okay
as as a follow-up to that he at the
beginning he had delusions and one of
his delusions was that his father was
not his father
so
i you know i don't know where he stands
on that right now the medication seems
to have taken care of the delusions but
for that reason should his father not be
part of this conversation
um i would ask him tell him we have to
have a hard conversation about our live
your living arrangements here
and would you like um i want dad to be a
part of this conversation but in the
past you have expressed that you didn't
know if dad was dad
um
are you okay with him being a part of
this conversation
okay and i just i would just have it
that way
um okay actually you know what i'll take
that back i absolutely take that back
yes i would have data part of the
conversation
i would okay here's why
um this is your house and this whole
conversation is a boundary where we're
reclaiming our home and we're reclaiming
our rightful place as your parents
and as your parents we're going to tell
you her truths and we're going to love
you
and so this is your dad
and
if you've taken your medication and
you're part of a healing community
then you would know that or you would at
least understand and trust us
right or trust your anyway
um
is that making sense
sure so i would have that this is a
reclamation thing but i need you to hold
this really like what i'm about to tell
you right now i need you to hold this in
your hand
this can all go south
and the question you have to ask
yourself is
is it worth that conversation
and what i will tell you is for me yes
for me yes
for the students for those folks i've
walked alongside year after year yes
it might be that you ask somebody from
the va to join you in this conversation
at home
it might be that you have the va on
standby or some sort of other mental
health professional in the community on
standby
it may be that you've got
two or three people that you trust that
are friends of the family that maybe he
trusts or a couple of his friends or
maybe one or two friends from
service with him
you will know best the ecosystem with
which to have this conversation
and it might not be just one
conversation might be multiple
but at some point we set a deadline and
say hey you're not getting better
you're struggling
if you're going to live here
you're going to be a part of this family
and here's what that looks like
and depending on where his mental ill
how severe is mental illness is he may
be
just i mean unable to function at 100
great
here's what based on what you can do
here's what we're asking of you
we've got to have signed releases with
your doctor so that we can be a part of
your healing journey gotta know what
meds you're taking and i get to check in
on you periodically to make sure you're
taking your meds
if you're struggling with delusions or
suicidal you're gonna let somebody know
that's an agreement that you make as i
promise you make to your mom and dad to
live in our home some of those things
right we're going to be very clear on
our boundaries
and you've got to have people that walk
alongside you as you rev these
conversations up because it's going to
be hard and he may walk right out that
door
okay i don't envy you in a
the slightest bit
i'm heartbroken for you but i also know
shying away from this is making the
whole house tense and the whole house
filled with smoke let's open the windows
up and let's have that conversation
get a professional walk along who will
walk alongside you in this okay don't do
this by yourself